Okay, Michael so enough of all
this hand-waving you like to do.
Let's actually write out some equations.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
>> There's no need to fear
the equations Michael.
So I'm going to leave our little picture
up so you can remember what it was
we're talking about, and
I'm going to leave out the definition or
the tuple part of what an option is so
that you remember that and
then I'm just going to write
an equation up here and here it is.
So V sub t + 1 of s = max over O
of the quantity R of (s,o) plus
sum over s prime of s, o,
s prime times V sub t of s prime.
What does that equation
look like to you?
>> It has a lot in common
with the Bellman equation.
>> Right and
in fact that's exactly what it is.
It is a rewriting of
the Bellman Operator.
So what do you think the various
constituent parts are?
>> Maybe an easier thing to
do would be to explain what
looks like it might be different.
>> Okay.
>> So for one thing, a has become o,
because I guess actions have become
possibly temporally extended actions.
>> Or options.
>> Or options, good.
Do we need to include
a in there as well?
Why, how can we ignore all the a's?
>> Well because the a's
are inside the o's.
>> The a's are inside the o's.
>> Yes.
>> There's actually an o inside an a.
>> Well I think that depends upon
whether it's a lowercase or capital a.
>> That's fair.
>> Thank you.
>> But i still don't quite understand.
So, you're saying options
are made out of actions.
>> Yes because there
may have little pulses.
>> But can you have an option
that is just an action?
>> Of course, right.
So options are a journalization
of actions.
If I wanted to take an action and
I wanted to turn it into an option,
then the initiation set would just be
everywhere where that action is valid.
The policy inside that option would just
say for whatever state I'm in, take that
action with probability one and all
other actions with probability zero and
then the termination probability
would be one for all of the states
that I can reach from that particular
state to particular action.
Actually would just be one everywhere.
>> One everywhere.
I see.
I say, that's okay.
That's actually really cute.
That kind of helps me understand
why these three quantities
are the way that they are.
So it allows it to specifically say,
yeah,
well we can always include an action
which is a primitive action, that just,
you can use it whereever
you can use the action.
It just does the action and
then it stops right away.
>> Right exactly.
>> Okay, all right, good.
So then the o, okay,
I get the o's generalizing the a.
Then another difference is there's
no discount factor that I can see.
And then the last difference is that
we seem to have spelled T as an F.
>> Right well, F and T are the same for
an appropriate kind of thinking about.
>> Only in logic.
>> Only in logic?
>> Yeah T and F are the same.
>> Actually they're
the opposite in logic.
>> Whoops.
>> Yeah, T is true and F is false.
I hadn't thought about that.
That's kind of an interesting thing
that we could talk about for an hour and
a half or
I could just explain to you what F is.
So you did the right thing, you noticed
that we still have a reward function as
we did before in the Bellman operator.
We still have value functions,
is what we're trying to do,
trying to update value over states.
We have little s's and the s primes,
the o's are basically a,
so that doesn't seem different, but
the two big differences are a lack of a
discount factor which isn't quite true.
We actually have a discount factor but
it's hidden and
instead of a transition model we have F.
So F is,
this really is a Bellman operator.
F is sort of, I think, clearly playing
the role of a transition function.
It's somehow telling you something
about states, options and next states.
And what I really need to do
to make this clear, I think,
is to just really write out what F is.
>> That would be super helpful.
>> That would be really nice, but
it turns out that I have to write out
something else as well and that is R.
So R look sort of superficially like
the reward function that we had before,
although, in this case the reward is
from you know taking a particular
option a particular state.
But actually this reward function is
hiding a lot of complexity as well and
to see what the complexity is I
think it helps to draw a picture.